what is your legacy for your body of  work you know the studio is gonna be  what it is this that's gonna be what it  is I tell you what I what I'm most  excited about next is that pulling this  this next phase off is building a  compound a for trafficked women girls  homeless women LGBTQ youth who are put  out and displaced and having a compound  that is a beautiful place right here on  somewhere on these three on thirty acres  where they're trained in the business  and they become self-sufficient they  live in nice apartments there's daycare  there's all these wonderful things that  allows them to reenter society and then  pay it forward again so that's that's  what I hope to do soon